so good afternoon I'm bill Wagner and
this Twitter handle on the slide so you
can contact me afterwards any way you
want it's also my github handle so with
any other questions go ahead and go to
the C sharp Docs repo and you can pose
questions and ask issues there so the
title of this
I chose rather deliberately so we're
what I want to have happen out of this
talk so I'm going to show you a variety
of different things that you can do with
the new features we've added into the
c-sharp language that should make you
more productive and should increase the
quality and the clarity of the code that
you write so what that does mean is as I
start each of the demos and I show some
code that looks like it could have been
written a few years ago I don't want you
to go back and go oh no I've got to
rewrite all this because that codes
probably been tested it certainly works
it's certainly in a good spot but as
we've been involving the language we
wanted to make that a little better
so the idea behind this is if you think
about computer languages programming
languages they are all opinionated they
were designed by people who thought
certain things and certain techniques
and certain goals were important other
things not so much so at the time of
their design in every instance they come
up with ideas that say we believe this
is the way you should write software and
this is how you should do it and they
made those things easy but if you look
at the arc of computer programming
languages they usually take a long time
to get get a lot of adoption and once
they do have a lot of adoption they take
a long time to stay in the industry
because there is so much code out there
that is using that language so every
programming language expresses opinions
in a lot of ways the programming
languages will have intentional opinions
we think this is a good way to solve
these kinds of problems some languages
and probably every language in some way
or other has ax
opinions I know we didn't think about
that
and now it's here right I mean every
language does so I'm not gonna try to
pick on any in particular here language
expresses opinions by making some things
easier and by making other things harder
and this is the thing that we're really
wrestling with and trying to do is we
continue to evolve the c-sharp language
if you look at the arc of our modern
more recent language releases we have
learned a lot of things as in industry
since the initial design of c-sharp in
round 1999-2000 so we want to make it
easier to create better software using
the techniques people are recommending
in general in 2020 and beyond that is
the only way the language will stay
relevant it's still gonna be an
object-oriented language that is where
its roots are we do not intend to take
any features away because that would
just be unwise there's too much code out
there but we also have recognized and
continue to recognize that things we may
have thought were good ideas or may have
thought were now this is easy enough in
99 or 2000 isn't easy enough anymore so
we want to make that better
so we are doing a lot of things to make
it easier to work with different kinds
of data one of the things that we
learned you know that if I look at the
arc of history in computer languages the
advent of Java and c-sharp was because
the industry finally realized after C
and C++ and other languages like that
that managing allocated memory was a
whole lot harder than anybody thought it
was see ya
malloc and free how hard could it be
right how many different bugs were
because of that C++ knew and delete and
different kinds of new and delete and so
on and smart pointers and so on better
still a problem wait to see sharp in
Java these things are easier but now
when you look there are still things
that we did not make as easy as we could
have
from things that we've now learned as an
industry with the kinds of programs that
we write now so it's important to start
to add those features so with that
introduction I'm really gonna spend the
rest of the time looking at code and
talking about the way we wrote things
and the recommendations we had and how
we would go about doing that now and
different things we've added to the
language that we want you to explore and
to start to adopt as habits every time
that you're working so the first thing
we're going to learn is if you work in
the area of computer languages
the only demos you're allowed to do
involve points and a person class
because they're easy to explain I don't
have to explain the domain we know what
a 2d point looks like we know what a
person object should be and points let
us work with value types very nice and
easily and person objects let us work
with reference types so I'm gonna start
with some things in our basic point
class I'm gonna shrink this down a
little bit they after changing are so
I've got x and y I can public gather a
private setter I know I can simplify
some of this and I will get to a fair
amount of it I have a design decision
that I want to calculate the distance
but I want to calculate it lazily so
I've got a nullable double to store the
distance and I've got a property that
retrieves the distance calculating it if
I need to I've got a constructor I've
got an operator equals operator not
equals because of that I have to
override equals and we've got a gitch
hashcode that I'm not gonna debate
whether that's a good get hash code or
not but it's keeping the compiler happy
and then just because I want to make
sure this is good for beginners I'm
going to show a neat little trick to get
you through that entry level programming
interview where everybody says I want
you to swap these values all right and
you know anyone has their first
programming interview it's like x equals
y y equals x oh you got it wrong you've
never had to write that code again but
just in case you do I'm going to show
you a neat trick
so a c-sharp 7 and we added tuples
and we added them just so that it was an
easy way not to have to write a class or
a struct every time he wanted to hold
more than one value right because that
was encouraging behavior that we didn't
like right we want to keep these things
together but then I got to write a class
I got to put all these things in there
I'm gonna define these methods and now I
suddenly got two pages of code just for
something you can make a lot of sense so
we put in tuples turns out once you have
these there's some really neat fun
tricks you can do so let's start here
with this constructor it looks like a
lot of constructors you would write for
any of the types that you create I've
got a set of private fields I've got a
set of arguments that come in and I'm
gonna set each private feel to that
argument and depending on how many
fields you have you get this different
life this is this this is that that's
that the other thing well let's just
write this in a real simple way now that
I've got two pools and I'm gonna go X
right X comma Y comma distance equals
and let's change that to this that X
because I gave them the same same casing
is that Y and that's going to equal X
comma y comma distance comma default and
then I don't need these lines okay
so I've just made one assignment that
says let's really temporarily just
create this tuple that has the private
fields that I want to initialize on the
left side and on the right side let's
just create another tuple that's got the
arguments I want to pass to it okay this
is one of the ones we do not have a code
fix or refactoring for and there are a
couple reasons for it this looks good
because it's got a total of three
variables and they're generally small in
practice when I'm writing code and when
I'm looking at different things I will
use this technique just about all the
time with two arguments I will often use
it with three depending on the length of
the variable names
four starts to look dumb so I usually
don't do that and then I would go back
to separate statements so if we were
gonna add a refactoring for this and
there's a called possible community
project to do it we would want to be
able to go through go both ways to be
able to say take these separate
statements and make it into a tuple
assignment take this tuple assignment
make it back into separate statements
because classes have a way of growing
fields occasionally over time so there's
that one well now as soon as you see
that then you start to look at something
and you go this operator equal equal
looks like it should do something a lot
like that and if you've ever done code
reviews you may often see depending on
the thoroughness of your tests that
sometimes in one of these you might miss
a left and a right or you might miss the
property names because we we copied and
pasted this right because that's what we
do so let's write it in a way that makes
it just a little bit easier so I'm gonna
go left out X comma left out y equals
right dot X and come right down Y okay
and then you see I don't need that extra
and in there I don't have to make sure I
get the that logic correct it's just
this tuple on the left that I quickly
create tuple on the right quickly create
life is good and we can do the same
thing of course with the not equal and
then because people copy and paste code
you know that at least in somewhere in
your code base instead of the or there
there's an and and it the logic is wrong
and here I can just go left out X left
out Y and it's just should not equal
right that X comma right that Y cool
I like it alright so now that's just a
little bit smaller it's really clear
what it means though that's just doing a
couple little tricks with tuples which
we'll have a few more as we keep going
through some other core themes all right
now I said we had this swap quartz thing
I know what we're gonna do now that's
now gonna be X comma y equals y comma X
take that nasty interview person with
your weird stupid programming questions
because that's gonna work okay
sitting with John skeet he showed me a
version of this where he does the same
kind of trick with the Fibonacci
sequence and you get you know this
current current neck's it's kind of cool
so we start to do things like that
because the way we defined this and we
said we had to do this for the language
is this going to evaluate all of the
expressions on the right side to create
that tuple and evaluate the expressions
on the left side to find the variables
those things store in and then do the
assignments so this will work correctly
and where we really needed that in
practice other than for tricks like this
is to be able to show things like you
could have expressions on either side
and things on the right side could
change what happens on the left and we
need to know exactly how that worked yes
so that's cool so that's the first part
that's just a few little trips tricks
with tuples anytime you're looking at a
couple maybe three sometimes four
variables that you want to have travel
together go ahead and put them in a
tuple and use it knee of these tricks
and again none of these really do
anything different than what we saw
before with the old code it is really a
visual and a take a look at it and see
if you like the way it looks for each
for individual classes and individual
struts that you're working with you know
if you write this and you've got five or
six things and it just looks bad or if
you've got some really long variable
names and it looks bad and don't
but this is just something when it
provides more clarity to what you're
right go ahead and and do just that so
now our next thing that I really want to
talk about that we added and this was
one that was added in the seven-point
releases where we did a lot of work to
make it more more better to write
read-only structs and we've been saying
to make value types immutable since
c-sharp 1.0 that was all on all of you
we really didn't provide a lot of
support for that so what we have done
now is let's say I said in my design you
know this really should have been an
immutable structu store these points I
don't want them being modified once I've
collected that data they should be never
changing so now I can add the read-only
modifier on the struct definition so if
I wanted this to be immutable I would do
that and now the compiler is you notice
I've got red squiggles going out all
over the place here because I didn't
make it an immutable type in that any of
the private member variables the
compiler now tells me those must be
read-only because they weren't this
would not compile furthermore anything
that tries to set any of those read-only
variables
well those can't be you know that's bad
- you've said this was supposed to be a
read-only struct now the impetus behind
this was performance in certain areas in
that now we want to be able to pass
trucks by references we want to be able
to do things like using span and reusing
memory and if the compiler can enforce
the fact that a struct doesn't change
and cannot be mutated then that is a
safer thing to do because we can pass
this struct by reference we know it
can't get modified and it's safe when it
comes back or as if you pass something
by reference and it could possibly be
modified the compilers going to make a
copy of it to make sure the codes
correct
so before I make this completely
read-only this is where it gets to a lot
of design decisions maybe I don't want
the whole thing to be read-only so
let's annotate what we can and say I
know this method doesn't modify state so
you know getting the export well that
should be read-only so I can put the
read-only modifier there to ensure that
the get accessor does not modify
anything inside this object okay that
may look redundant but it really isn't
because of property we know execute code
so you could change state there again
we'll do the same thing with the
read-only on the on the Y and then here
on distance right that shouldn't change
state he said so we'll write the
read-only modifier on that property
quick thing to note if you have only a
get accessor you cannot put the
read-only modifier on the get accessor
you have to put it on the property ok
and if you notice as soon as I do that
I'm now getting an error and another
warning saying yeah you can't do this
because you said this was read-only
right so by saying it was read-only
you're not allowed to modify the thing
and now you really have a design
decision to make as to what you wanted
to do if you wanted to make this
completely read only or if you wanted to
still allow this lazy evaluation to go
on now let's say every time I create a
point in this particular application I'm
always going to calculate the distance
well then I would probably move that
calculation up into the constructor and
really make this read-only and cache
that value let's say only 1 out of 1,000
points I'll calculate the distance then
maybe I don't want to pay that cost and
I would say ok I'm not going to make
this read-only and then note that
because this is going at the getting set
properties it doesn't give me a warning
here it's going to just say the same
thing so it's here what we're trying to
get at and what we want you to be able
to do is anytime that you're looking at
a struct only this read-only modifier
cannot be added
classes anytime you're creating a struct
if your design was to make it an
immutable struct add the read-only
modifier on the struct if it was meant
to be only some things are read-only
then add it to those methods so I'm
going to finish this up because I do
want to show one or two other techniques
that we've added is I am going to make
this read-only and then we are going to
deal with some of these these errors is
now I'm going to use an implicit
property here and now I'm just going to
say well this is just just has a get
access err and I am going to use the
read-only property syntax when you do
this whether it's in a read-only struct
or not the compiler knows the code it
generates and it automatically makes
that property a read-only as the
read-only modifier to it and il so that
the CLI will know that that that X
property is a read-only really read-only
property and will do the same thing with
Y and delete that
I love deleting code and getting
features and now that's of course going
to be read-only as well I could add the
read-only modifier here if I wanted to
but it is redundant it doesn't add
anything it's already there so now I'm
going to have to change how I do the
distance I'm going to remove the
nullable attribute on it and here I'm
just going to do the same trick I'm
going to make this a get only accessor
I'm going to get rid of all that do this
and you know math dot square root x
times X plus y times y all right and
again you can see this gets just a
little bit longer and this should be
distance and these become capitals
because I need to use the properties
okay and now I have a truly read-only
struct and now I have to just remove
that because that was done for a bug
somebody was just any data backwards so
we needed that for a little bit but now
I haven't truly read-only struct now the
point of this trick in the point of what
I want to say is this should enforce
what your design is add these modifiers
to enforce the design it will
communicate to other developers what you
meant someone comes in here later and
wants to add a method and I call the
read-only modifier was probably there
for a reason maybe I shouldn't add
something in the mutate state maybe I
should do something to create a new
point based on the existing data however
I wanted to modify it so you communicate
that design to others and you
communicate it to the compiler the
compiler will now help you enforce your
design okay now a little bit of a sneak
as to our next trick what we're going to
do the other big feature we added in
c-sharp eight is knowable reference
types and once you get to dotnet core
3.1 more and more of the base class
libraries have been annotated so that
the api's now have the noble annotations
so for instance I have no bubbles turned
on here and if I have a method that
looks like this I'm now getting a green
squiggle here which is warning what that
is telling me is as of dotnet core 3.1
the equals override has now been
annotated with object could be null so
it's an object question mark okay then I
have to put that there
okay this is one of the reasons why
officially c-sharp eight is not
supported on older frameworks while the
nullable reference types feature for one
is a big one that it's implemented
completely compiler so the compiler
would do the right thing
the older libraries have not been
annotated which causes two bad effects
you will get warnings at times when you
shouldn't and you won't get warnings at
some of the times when you should
so because of that it really doesn't
help as much and it really would provide
kind of a false sense of security if you
added this into your code and expect
everything to be good but you're not
getting annotations from the libraries
you use between now and net five and
then net six we're going to continue to
add more annotations into more of the
dotnet libraries based on how many based
on usage usage and download statistics
that we have for which classes and which
API is get use the most is it is quite a
bit of work to annotate everything so
between now and that net five nine and
six as you start adopting c-sharp eight
and nullable reference types with each
new release you may start to see a few
new warnings because more api's have
been annotated but that should be
pointing out potential errors in your
code so we'd still want you to encourage
you to start looking at it and start
considering annotating your own code and
turning this on where you can so next
I'm going to get to as we talked about
this and we start adding this here's
something that we've learned over the
course of time nullable reference makes
the null reference exception is the
single most reported exception on any
dotnet app anywhere in the planet it is
more than double any other exception
type that we ever see in any telemetry
that we see looking at open source
projects on github
checking for null is the single biggest
expression and work that people do in
code so let's do everything we can to
make that more efficient so that you can
add null checks without muddying the
rest of your algorithms and I'm gonna
admit I'm totally guilty of this because
I do a lot of work in Docs and writing
samples and we often don't check for
null because the more null checks we add
the harder it is to figure out the
algorithm that we're trying to explain
so instead of writing the code you would
really have to write in production we
trimmed some of these out and we're we
want to change that habit ourselves as
well and in doing this we're going to do
some things to add things to the
language to make null checks not take so
many lines of code
so let's look at our override of equals
it's right now it's it's in at about ten
lines of code there is really only one
line of code here that has anything to
do with the algorithm at all and that's
the one that calls our operator equals
that says this is value based equality
check to see if all the properties are
equal that's cool the rest of it is all
related to the null check that's bad so
let's try to shrink this out a little
bit so let's do this and say alright so
this if object is point other pt we're
going to add some things with pattern
matching so I'm just going to clear that
here and then well now I'm just going to
return this equals that I still need the
bracket sorry don't want to get into
that bug and now I have that okay so now
I've I've shrunk that a little I'm
feeling a little better it's a little
bit more clear to see what you want okay
now this is one that it depends on how
you like the ternary operator or not but
I can turn this into a single line
expression and I can return is point
other PT question mark
boom yeah if not just return false okay
and I would usually try to format that
like this okay so now we have a very
concise null check here if object is a
type of a point if you've been a c-sharp
program for a long time you knew that is
for a long time only worked with
reference types not with value types
works with value types and now we can
say it is and has an assignment in the
same statement and then we're gonna just
check equality if that test succeeded if
not and if it was null it is not a point
so the is operator only returns true if
the object is not null whether it's a
reference type or a value type in all
there would always return false because
it's not an object it's nothing okay so
there we go slightly simplified way of
doing null checks but to really do null
checks you know remember I said I do
either person classes or points so yeah
now let's go over the person type we've
got some reference properties and we
have the same kind of thing here what
I've got is I've got a person with first
name and last name and we've got you
know more than half of this code is the
null track stuff okay thankfully though
if you look closely you'll see three
dots at the throw because this is
something we we wanted to start
encouraging and we say use a throw
expression what does that do no okay so
now if you look what this does I'm gonna
add a carriage return here to make this
little bit easier and as well just
change this to the expression bodied
members because you know the brackets
are just taking up space for no apparent
reason and I now have a set that says
all right so first name equals value and
then a double question mark just null
coalescing operator and if value happens
to be null then throw in your argument
no exception okay so I like that I also
like the way intellisense did that for
me another little trick here that is my
single biggest complaint about API
consistency in the.net libraries is
argument null exception the parameter
name is first and the message is next in
the argument exception they're reversed
thank you very much so in all cases if
you look at our Docs what we try to do
is we try to use name parameters even
though we often put them in the normal
order and then in order to make sure
refactoring works we use the name of
operator for the param name just because
then if I refactor this and I change the
name of the argument that code will also
be refactored
so we can do the same thing here in this
next one I've got the same kind of thing
cool hit our light bulb and use the
throw expression
hey I can do it here and in my
constructor - I'm now feeling really
good about this yeah I can do the same
one there and if you notice that I did
all the null checks first and then the
assignments and this refactoring knows
enough to start to move those around and
see those anywhere in a method so with
most of the methods you'd write you do
something like I'm going to test all the
arguments first and then I'm going to go
on and I'll do more things later the
next one that I want to look at here is
we added a method onto this person class
to hyphenate last name for a partner so
I could do a dot - 8b or depending on
how the partners wanted to switch like a
DB dot - a day and get a new last name
that has the concatenation of those and
you can see I have to check to see if
partner is null and if it's not in all
I'm gonna do this work to set last name
and if it is now I'm gonna throw a null
VAR argument exception now I wrote this
in a slightly different way because I
wanted to show something very important
about the way the warnings get generated
my mark said earlier in this project I
have turned on turned on nullable
reference types and I have all the
warnings turned on so if you look at
this argument this person argument it
should be and it is declared to be a non
knowable reference type okay so if I
delete this null check and I just wanted
to leave the null track
okay I am not getting any warning any
errors or warnings to say you might be
dereferencing something that's null here
this is not good because I declare it to
be not nullable and then put the null
Trax back and I'm going to point out
that with your code when the compiler
looks at anything that you've annotated
with null reference types it pays
attention to what you're doing and it
does do a thorough static analysis of
your code and what you've already
written so this partner is a non
nullable reference type but down here if
I do a console dot write line and I
could do partner dot last name okay now
there it is I now have a warning under
partner the green squiggles that is a
nullable reference warning and if I
hover over it it is going to say you
know this you might be dereferencing
null here okay even though the type was
declared the argument was declared as a
non nullable reference type because you
added this null check the compiler goes
I bet you did that for a reason crazy
human programmer so because you did that
for a reason and this line of code this
console dot write line is not inside the
block where you have checked it against
null maybe you really is null here so
I'm not going to trust the type system
quite so much right there that's sort of
the key to what not nullable reference
types are they are annotations on
variables it's not a new type and we're
doing static analysis of the code to
determine should we issue a warning here
so as you're adding things when you have
null reference checks those will affect
the static analysis I am NOT encouraging
you to remove null reference checks just
so you know but I am pointing out what
will happen with warnings however there
is a neat trick that we can do to make
these null reference checks simpler
again I'm going to want to throw this no
reference exception with if this is bad
so I'm gonna move this up here and I
don't want to do a no reference check
with this if
because this is just it's really old
school but what I'm gonna want it to is
I would like to use that same kind of a
throw expression but if you look at that
line of code where I do the return I'm
just using person I don't really need to
assign this to anything so I'm going to
use a discard I'm gonna say discard
equals partner or throw that in all
reference exception argument null
exception okay so the discard here is a
special token that says if I don't
already have a variable named underscore
there this looks like a variable but the
compiler can throw it away and in fact
does not store anything to it so this is
something we think is going to be
idiomatic that we would like to
encourage people to use more and more
which is if all you're really trying to
do is check to see whether an argument
or a field or whatever is null assign
that field to a a discard and when you
have it and if the right hand side of
that assignment is null add the question
mark question mark throw and that's a
null Chuck now the reason to do this you
know we talk kind of about writing less
code and I and I really think that
that's less important than making your
actual algorithm stand out more clearly
the original version of this was about
four lines long and more than half of
the code in it was a null check and the
throw we've now changed that in all
check into a single assignment statement
with an expression on it and then while
this is a one-line method so it is
reasonably simple whatever else you're
doing now becomes the code that you
would really look at right so what we're
trying to do is make it so these these
techniques that we have to use all the
time just to ensure our code is correct
and things don't crash and we don't get
calls at weird hours takes up less of
the code so that we can see that it's
correct and we can really concentrate on
the logic that we've written so for the
last larger set of demos that I want to
work with is
dealing with pattern-matching which is
something that we think is a really
better way to write a lot of the
algorithms that we have to write as
we're working with data as working with
data of different types and different
properties and we're bringing data from
different places possibly as JSON
packets either from rest or graph QL and
maybe looking at it and parsing it we
need to create different object types
and so on so the idea behind this is
this is part of the system that does
toll calculations so I'm going to start
with the set of comments so imagine a
large metropolitan city shouldn't be too
hard right now and we want to discourage
traffic at times that there's already an
incredible amount of traffic so there's
a toll system that does charges people
to use the roads at peak times so the
business people of complan have said all
right so here's what we're gonna do on
the weekends tolls are just its normal
cost if you go overnight on a week night
well that's when we want the lorries to
do the deliveries and so on so we're
gonna even lower it further so if it's
the wee hours of the morning you only
pay 75% of the normal toll day time so
not rush hour but after morning rush
room before afternoon rush well it's
still pretty busy in the city so you pay
one-and-a-half times if you're morning
rush going into the city it's double
evening rush going out of the city is
also double okay so I made a few small I
made an enum for morning rush daytime
evening rush overnight is weekday okay
this is a pattern matching switch
expression okay so if you squint at it
it kind of looks a little bit like a
switch statement but these are all
expressions so you know it's a lambda
arrow and the right-hand side is always
an expression it is not a set of
statements or a block and there's no
break we did switch the order and this
is so that you can change them I can
make the output of one switch feed into
another switch expression because then
that makes it a little bit more fluent
so I'm gonna take what day of the week
is it and I'm gonna switch on that value
so that's an enum in the day time class
they times struct and of course has
Sunday Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday and I'm gonna say if
it's Saturday or Sunday well it's not a
weekday anything else which is this
discard character and a switch statement
is match everything else well then it is
a weekday so return return true this is
a really good way to look at bits of
data and make a determination about the
values or the properties or the types of
that data in this instance I'm making a
determination based on the values of
veneno so here when I did the time band
well this talks about how worse we are
still innovating and we are still going
to add more we don't have a range
pattern patterns have to be a particular
value so if I take the hour I would need
24 rows here to match every different
possible value 0 through 23 and that
would look really ugly so here I am
using some nested ifs one of the
proposals that we're looking at right
now is a range pattern that would say if
our was between 0 & 6 or between 6 and
10 you know and we're looking at a way
to add that which would simplify this
guy so again going back to what I said
at the very beginning this isn't
necessarily go rewrite all your code use
pattern matching look for places where
it would make sense speaking of places
where it would make sense so let's look
at an imperative way to calculate that
multiplier okay the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to check to see
if it's a weekday if it is a weekday I
want to look if you're going into the
city if you're going into the city then
I want to look as morning rushes the
daytime is evening rush oh it's
something else that must be overnight
okay this else matches inbound so now
you're leaving the city so let's get the
time of the tool I'm already off the
page so I made the same call again I
could probably refactor this but this is
already really long and I wanted to
remember what it was
and again more is it morning what is it
in the evening what is it overnight and
so on and then we get back to this last
else oh that's the weekend so the
multiplier is one okay this code does
not fit on one page it ends on line 95
it starts on line 46 so we have almost
50 lines of code and yes I know I'm
following some coding standards that
have braces we could remove the braces
and we could shrink it but that leads to
bugs so I'm not doing that that 50 line
method is implementing those what six
lines of business requirements including
the comment that says this is exactly
these are the business requirements so
five different business requirements 50
lines of code it's that good business
people are not going well about how much
did you test this did you go through
everything how do you are you sure this
is something where we can really use
pattern matching so we'll go ahead and
implement this here from the pattern
matching bed so I repeated the same
business requirements here and now if
you look at this once again I'm gonna
use those tuples because now I've got
three variables
I'd like to make into one thing but I'm
not going to define a class to hold
whether or not it's a weekday which time
band and is it whether or not you're
going into or out of the city so I just
made a tuple out of those three
variables here on line 106
I've got his weekday time of toll get
time bad time toll inbound then I've got
the switch and now I can build a table
with all the combinations of all those
values copy and paste helped here and I
didn't want you to watch me type all
that but so there is this is what I need
to fill in those lines don't take a
picture yet a salt zero is this is broad
okay so the first thing I can do is they
look at my requirements all right so the
weekend everything should be 1.0 great
so I'm going to start here at the first
false handle visual studio check if you
press down alt you can select on a
column so I'm going to just select this
one column down there not quite there
that's close enough and now just delete
that one and then I can just write the
one in there okay that's cool so now I
fill that half the table life is good
so now I've got okay so what did I say
day time was I said day time was always
going to be one or one and a half yes
daytime is one and a half okay great so
I need a 5 here and a 5 here morning
rush if I'm going into the city is
double if I'm going out it's the same
overnight oh that was one 0.75 because
you get a discount for the laurie's
going in overnight and then evening rush
I said that was going to be no wait I
just messed this up didn't I these are
so I was already in the wrong row that
should be those were supposed to be the
zeros that's still the weekend okay and
then up here I've got evening rush going
home is 2 going in is one day time I
said that was gonna be 1.5 for both of
them great morning rush going home or
leaving the city is one going in is 2
okay great now I've got that that's
that's not not that hard to really
comprehend now right I've got 12 rows
it's not bad okay but we can still
simplify this a fair amount and again
here I would really look at the code
look at the options that you have look
at how many rows you have how many
different values you have to decide how
far to go down this next set of
refactoring I'm gonna do everything on
the weekend back here with the falses
well that's all all 1.0 I don't care
what any other value is so I'm just
gonna add a row here that does false
don't care don't
and that is gonna be one point oh okay
now notice how I get the red squiggles
on all of the lines below it this is
will help you test if you're doing any
of these you refactorings to see if you
got it right by doing any of these
refactorings with the warning or the
errors and all of these says this which
arm was already handled by something
above it so there's no way to execute
this code because the statement above it
it's always gonna get handled okay
that was exactly what I wanted so that's
good now I can take these and I can
delete them cool turns out if I want to
be really fussy I can make this just
another discard because well once I've
handled all the true cases I don't care
okay but we'll wait to do that one last
now there's a couple other ones I can do
here I look anything overnight is that
0.75 so whether it's true or false I can
replace this with a discard okay and if
I do that this one should turn red cool
that was exactly what I wanted okay and
then okay anything at the day time
that's also one and a half I can do that
cool and then this one should turn red
there we go that's done okay that's nice
cool okay I don't like the way this
looks it's it's correct it's about as
simple as I can get it but you know I'd
like to kind of just let's just move
this one up here and I'll leave the 1.0
is together okay and then I've got the
ones that have thumb of that since it
didn't add any squiggles well okay I'm
okay I put him in an order that still
works so now we took this thing that was
50 lines of code that was very
imperative if then else if else if else
if else that the other thing all of
one-line branches and we said you know I
can turn that into first it was 12 rows
and now it's down to 6 rows and the real
kicker that I want is not the amount of
code that you're writing and how
much of this there is but how clear is
that versus how clear is that and it
merely this is a little bit of a
contrived example and you should play
with this a little bit to figure out
what works in your code and in your code
bases but a lot of times when we're
looking at properties looking at types
or looking at values of data and we are
making decisions on an algorithm this is
an incredibly powerful tool to use and
the more I've started to play with us
and the more I've started to use it I
find myself going I really want to reach
for this tool very often okay so as
we're getting close to the end I'm going
to end with one really small quiz I
don't want anyone to speak up with this
but I'm gonna write a routine and this
routine is gonna have a bug in it and
when you spot the bug I want you to
raise your hand so now this told people
the business people have come back and
said alright this system is working but
we want to kind of reward people who are
really regular and following things so
we're gonna allow people to get a
year-long subscription and pay in
advance
because of some cash up front we like
that and then you know they can you know
be like frequent drivers and do
something better so I'm gonna make a
public static method that's going to
return a date time for the start and AJ
time for the end and the method is going
to be called generate subscription and
what it's going to do well we need to
figure out the start starts going to be
today so far a start equals date time
dot now dot date and you know it's going
to expire one year from now so I'm going
to do var and equals new date time I'm
going to do start dot year plus one
start got month because it's the same
day right start that day
okay all right I'm seeing tragically few
hands come up so to make sure everybody
can see the code well I'm going to leap
over here this is a bug that's gonna
show up one month from yesterday there
are not enough hands about that that was
a pretty good hit okay so everybody's
got that what is this gonna do that's
gonna be really bad anybody raise your
hand really early good on the 29th of
February 2020 this is going to crash
because there is no 29th of February
2021 now the point of this little quiz
is date time math is really really hard
because this is probably the most
obvious example and I did it here today
because it is very timely so a better
way to do this keeping this one fairly
simple is start dot add years one okay
because the dotnet Franco and I need to
add the return start and the reason I
did that out of that there's now the
date time struct and any good day time
library is going to handle all kinds of
conditions whether it's a leap here
whether it's yours it end in double zero
that you'd think are leap years but
aren't going on and going off summer
time if you're doing math around hours
and so on if you're doing really
extensive stuff around culture john
skeets not--it i'm open source library
is incredibly powerful and does a lot
more for a lot of reasonable things it's
built in a date time but they did this
in particular because i would actually
look at your code a little bit and maybe
do a quick search to see if you're just
doing your own date time math and try
and replace it with something that's
probably tested okay so that's the code
as we get close so the new habits the
reason we went through all of these
things and the reason I did some of this
little light-hearted but focusing on a
few different areas fun with tuples
anytime you find yourself going I'm
carrying a few bits of data and I really
don't want to do all the work to make a
struct think about using tuples there's
also a proposal that we're working on
for records which would be a very very
short and better simpler syntax actually
create a type if you needed it
read-only members and read-only struct
declare your intent when you're writing
structs and value types and let the
compiler enforce that and communicate it
both of the compiler and to everyone
who's going to read and maintain your
code has a better chance of being
correct over the long haul the examples
I was showing where I was doing the
question mark question mark
initializations and other things like
that the technique we refer to that as
is natin all by initialization so the
more often you can ensure that a field
or an argument or a variable is
initialized to something that does not
null as soon as you declare it and
create it at that point in text then you
know that variable is never null and you
can declare it as a non null reference
type and you will the compiler will help
you spot those errors remember that
those are just in metadata so especially
in public api's especially as you're in
this process where you're probably
migrating some code and some of it
hasn't been annotated check for nulls
anyway and especially in public api's as
I said anything that we're doing we're
annotating api's I can guarantee you we
are not removing null chats patterns and
data anytime you find yourself like
switching on things and doing a lot of
if-then-else some kind of logic by
looking at a property looking at a type
consider pattern matching it is a
different way of thinking about a
problem but it is a very very powerful
way for certain classes of problem this
is not to say stop using object-oriented
stop using inheritance would never want
to say that but if you looked at those
algorithms
I wrote I really didn't have an
inheritance hierarchy to work with but
have been really cumbersome one to make
one that switch expression was actually
much more powerful and a lot more clear
in a smaller space for exactly what the
code was doing that's what we're looking
for and then the classic because I just
really remind her date and time math and
what I would make the recommendation
here is do what you can to follow the
good engineering software engineering
practices that you're doing for your
applications I'm sure all of you are
building some kind of a culture of
trying to write good software when that
feels cumbersome do a little bit of
research see if there's a better way to
follow the really good practices without
writing quite as much extra code
specifically look for some new features
and recommendations I used the light
bulb today and there's also a
screwdriver icon for other
recommendations for purpose if you're
using Visual Studio then you will get
hints on some of the things that we
think we've added features that you may
not know about check that light bulb on
the screwdriver and I meant this bit
about talking about looking for the new
research and do some research
we love Stack Overflow and we love that
it helps me every day too but very often
now what we're finding because dotnet
has been around for about twenty years
is there are answers that have 15 years
of uploads and they were great perfect
answers for a long time and we've added
features to make that yeah this will
work but you know there's a better way
to do it and the better way has maybe
six months of upvotes so it's harder to
find it and like Tessa was talking about
in her opening keynote yesterday that's
a positive feedback loop people keep
seeing that first answer and using it
even though there may be a better way so
when I say do some research take a
little bit more time including Stack
Overflow we're trying very hard to stay
up to date on Docs and check the
recommendations from the IDE to try to
find some slightly better things and use
the things that we're adding to build
some new build some new habits I could
add ms / new c-sharp is where that's
going to point to the latest c-sharp
stuff
I'm going to particularly call out two
things that I put in here if you go into
the sample browser which is Doc's that
Microsoft comm slash samples and search
for Explorer c-sharp you will see any of
the things that we have that are going
to help you explore some new things and
new areas that one day I'll show another
thing that we're doing is we have
started adding a dotnet Docs what's new
page so every month we will be
publishing you know what's really big
and new and as a bonus because we're all
open source we are recognizing everybody
who contributed to Doc's in the last
month by their github IDs and if they
have added their name to the github
profile we will put it there but we
don't dig any deeper than that and if
you look at our tutorials the toll
calculator is part of a much larger
application on pattern matching that
will take you up through a lot more
techniques that you can use there thank
you for your time I sure everybody's
excited to get to the reception but I
will be up here for any questions you
can ask me questions now what I think
we've got a couple minutes left and
thank you very much for your time
[Applause]